authorities in germany have now voiced
their concerns over a reluctance to take
the kovit 19 jab
amongst the german population let's
speak to
professor uvei janssen's former
president of the german
interdisciplinary association of
critical care and emergency
medicine and dr jensen thank you very
much for being with us
um why are we seeing vaccine hesitancy
in germany
yes you just mentioned some of the
problems um
in the beginning in and of 220
there was a great hesitancy concerning
the
messenger rna vaccines
almost in the very big group
of healthcare workers some of them
feared that these kind of vaccines could
influence their genetic material or
would lead to
infertility so we had to do a lot of
information
for medical healthcare workers for
nurses
on the one hand on the other hand we had
to inform the population on this so
then the vaccine program started in
end of december on the 27th of december
in germany the rollout of the vaccines
and first we started with the biontech
vaccine and afterwards the moderna
vaccine and
then the discussion started about the
efficacy
of the astra cynica the jedox
vaccine which was prepared together with
oxford and many of the people
feared that these would be inferior
to the messenger rnav excellence from
biontech
and from modena which is contrary to the
evidence that we're getting isn't it
yesterday a study
for the population of scotland showing
very high
efficacy of 94 percent uh within four
weeks of the first dose of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine also high
85 percent on the pfizer biontech
vaccine
but given the briefings given the
tone of messaging we've heard from
politicians across europe was this
inevitable
yes i think there are so many points
which are
very critical and crucial for the
vaccine hesitancy among the population
as i can tell you in cologne a very very
big town in the western part of germany
the vaccine centers they want to
apply the estrocenic vaccine and they
have
appointments and the people do not show
up i
think it's a very critical point at this
time
and we have to do a lot of good
communication to transport
the scientific evidence which clearly
shows
the efficacy of the as the cynical
vaccine
and to transport this information in the
population and i can tell you that
much of the press and much of tv and
much of the radios
they worked on a negative image of these
vaccines and that
we are very very sad about it because we
really
we really think that the vaccine at this
moment
at this time in the corona pandemic is
the only solution to get
out of this disaster so at the moment we
are
very very eagerly trying to inform the
population to inform
medical healthcare workers about the
safety and about the efficacy of all
the vag science which at the moment
applied in germany
the figures when when you read them are
pretty startling
um only 150 000 out of 1.5 million
doses of the vaccine were used in
germany
on friday at one vaccination center in
berlin fewer than
200 people turning up for the
3 800 daily appointments given that the
damage that this
virus has done how surprised are you
by the low take-up
yes you see the population people are
always
very very very skeptic about
vaccines and in germany uh this is
uh i'm very sad about this it it just
dries up the skepticism
and i think it's uh uh um
[Music]
we see that this is the result of
this information misinformation and the
result of many many uh fake news
which are transported towards the social
medias and i think um the medical
societies on the one hand and the
politicians on the other hand they
couldn't uh get the good information
uh to the people so uh you see we know
that you have to have confidence in the
vac sign and this is a very very
critical point that people
are not whatever the reason is confident
in this
astrocytic vaccine which really proves
to be much more efficacy
than the influenza vaccine for incense
and
now the data are showing up and you just
mentioned it
uh that after the just one dose
astrazeneca after 90 days
there is a efficacy a severe coverage
about nearly 100 so we must convince the
people who must
try to talk to them and say then come on
get the vaccine
and i remember that in the beginning end
of
2020 in my own department there were
some of the nurses and healthcare
workers so i don't want to get vaccines
so we started a program within our
hospital about the
nationwide program for healthcare
workers to enhance
the exception uh acceptance of the uh
vaccine and we could show uh within um
online surveys that the the skepticism
uh gets down uh in december it was fifty
percent said of the healthcare workers
the nurses no i don't want to gather x
and now we are
only 25 percent of them saying oh i'm
i'm very critical about that so we are
getting nearer to the point that
to the hundred percent acceptance of the
vexa
where do you stand on the debate of
whether healthcare workers should have a
choice
in this matter our chief medical officer
was asked about this
yesterday at a downing street news
conference and talked about
a professional responsibility to protect
yourselves
and others when you are working within
the health sector
yes we had some of these discussions in
germany
in the beginning january and uh all the
end of year of 2020
but i can tell you and uh it's a
worldwide
phenomenon that uh healthcare workers
show some um hesitancy
about vaccine that's not only the
problem i think in germany
many other countries and there are some
very good studies
showing uh in the center of the epidemic
corona happening that health co-workers
are some way reluctant so they think
that the studies were done too fast they
think that the
messenger rnr the beginning could
influence their fertility
or their genes so there are some some
very fancy reasons to do not accept but
to to oblige to to say to them you have
the obligation
to get the vaccine i think that would
lead
to a very very big much more hesitancy
to get the vaccination so i think the
ways to convince
people to to tell them that the
vaccination has a
very very good efficacy without any
serious adverse event and we must have
the
publicity the the news the radius and
the tv
to improve the compliance of
anyone um in the population and not only
the healthcare workers in germany in
january
54 accepted to say i get the vaccine and
that that's not enough
to get rid of the subscribe to virus